♪ [music] ♪
So now that we have a measure of the
quality investment, what next?
To look at what next,
let's think about the trade-off on debt.
On the trade-off on debt,
I talked about the two significant
benefits that debt brings into the game.
The biggest is the tax benefit.
Interest is tax deductible,
cash flows to equity in most parts of the
world are not. So when I borrow money,
I create a tax benefit.
The higher my marginal tax rate,
the greater the tax benefit,
the more I should borrow.
There is a secondary benefit to debt.
Sometimes, in some companies,
borrowing money can make the company more
disciplined in the way it picks projects.
That can help you in terms
of increasing value.
Those two benefits have to be weighed
off against three significant costs.
The first is a bankruptcy cost.
When you borrow money,
you increase the likelihood of bankruptcy.
The expected bankruptcy cost is a product
of that likelihood of probability
of bankruptcy and the cost of bankruptcy.
The cost of bankruptcy can be either
direct cost, the cost occurred after you
go bankrupt, or an indirect cost,
which is a function of what happens to
your company when people think you're
in trouble. There is an agency cost.
Every time you borrow money,
you create a potential for conflicts,
conflict between equity investors
and lenders, and it's usually resolved by
putting constraints on the company,
covenants in loan agreements.
As you borrow money,
you're increasing those constraints,
and that's got to be factored into your
debt decision. And finally,
every time you borrow money,
you give up some future flexibility.
So from a purely qualitative standpoint,
if you ask me, should I borrow money,
it's this tradeoff that drives
that decision. Now, you can, of course,
convert this trade-off
into an actual choice.
So when we look at the optimal mix of debt
and equity, we bring that trade-off into
play into the cost of capital.
So here's what happens.
As you borrow more money,
you are replacing more expensive equity
with cheaper debt. That's good news,
but as you borrow more money,
here's what you're doing to your cost
of equity and your cost of debt.
Your cost of equity is going to become
higher because your equity investors bear
more risk when you borrow more money.
We show this as a higher beta and a higher
cost of equity. Your lenders will also see
more risk in you as you borrow more money,
so the default spreads that they charge
will go up, and with that,
the cost of debt will go up.
It's the net effect that drives your cost
of capital. And as we saw,
as you initially borrow money,
your cost of capital might go down,
but as you borrow more and more money,
there's a tipping point at which your cost
of capital starts to increase.
Your optimum mix of debt and equity is the
one that maximizes your value as a
business by minimizing your cost
of capital. Now, in terms of getting to
that optimal mix, we'd added some caveat.
There are two basic questions you need to
address once you have an optimal mix,
how quickly do I need to move to that mix?
And in what form? To answer the
first question, we asked,
how much your urgency is there in the fact
that your actual debt ratio is different
from the optimal?
For an under-levered firm,
a firm with too little debt,
the question we asked was,
how likely is it that you'll be taken
over? The greater the likelihood,
the quicker the move has to be.
With an over-levered firm,
one with too much debt,
the question we asked was,
are you under bankruptcy threat?
If you're under bankruptcy threat,
you need to do something quickly.
So the question of whether you move fast
or slow to your optimal will depend on how
much your urgency there is in the process.
But once you've made the decision,
you still have to decide how to move
to the optimal, and there are two ways you
can do it. One is you can recapitalize,
change your mix of debt and equity.
The second is you can take new projects.
Which one you choose will depend on
whether you've good projects.
If you have good projects,
my recommendation is you borrow the money
to take those projects if you're
under-levered, or raise equity to take
those projects if you are over-levered.
You'll get a double whammy.
Not only do you move to your optimal mix
of debt and equity and thus increase
your value, but you also get a positive
net present values of the projects
you take. Now, in terms of the right kind
of debt for your company,
the answer is very simple.
Tell me what kind of assets you have
as a company, the projects you take,
and I'll give you the right kind of debt
for your company. If your assets are
long-term assets that generate cash flows
in euros, the right kind of debt for you
is long-term euro debt.
By matching up your debt to your assets,
here's what you do. You're able to borrow
more money without exposing yourself to
default risk. You get the best
of both worlds. You get debt that behaves
like equity. You get the tax advantages
with all of the flexibility of equity.
In the context of dividend policy,
the key number we talked about was
potential dividend, the free cash flow
to equity. The free cash to equity is the
cash left over after you've met every
conceivable need, CapEx, working capital,
debt payments. That is what you can
pay out. And remember,
that free cash flow to equity can be a
negative number. So let's start easy.
If you have negative free cash flows
to equity, you have no business returning
cash to your stockholders.
If you have positive free cash flows to
equity, you can choose to return all of it
or none of it. And if you decide to return
none of it, your cash balance
will increase. Is that a bad thing?
Not necessarily if investors trust you
with the cash. The key word I said in
dividend policy is trust.
To the extent that you've earned the trust
of your investors, you can
accumulate cash. If they don't trust you,
they're going to demand their cash back,
and who can blame them? And finally,
when you turn to valuation,
make a decision just like you did in
capital budgeting. Are you valuing just
the equity in the business? In which case,
here is what you need to do.
Estimate the cash flows to equity,
which can be in the simplest example
dividends or in the more expensive example
of free cash to equity,
discount them back at the cost of equity,
come up with the value of equity
in the company. If you decide to value the
whole business, the process gets
more complex. You estimate pre-debt cash
flows, free cash flows to the firm,
you discount those back at the cost of
capital, you come up with the value of the
operating assets. Then tie up the loose
ends. Add cash, add cross holdings,
subtract debt, and if you have equity
options, take care of those before you
come up with a value per share.
Overall of this, I've kept referring back
to the big picture. So let me return and
end this class with the same big picture
that we started this class with.
Let me repeat again the three principles
that govern corporate finance and let's
see if, at the end of 36 sessions,
there's a little more heft to each of
these principles. The first principle is
the investment principle.
Here's what it says,
"When you as a company go out and make
investments, make sure you earn a return
that is greater than your hurdle rate,"
but now, we have a basis
for those returns. Those return should be
based on cash flows,
should reflect the timing of those cash
flows, and have all side effects built
into them. That's investment return
process. The hurdle rate should reflect
the risk of the investments,
and we've talked about what type of risk
should be in the hurdle rate,
and should also reflect where you get
your money, the mix of debt and equity.
The financing principle has two
sub-principles to it.
The right financing mix for your company
is the one that minimizes your hurdled
rate and maximizes your value,
so look for that mix.
And the right kind of debt for your
company is the one that best matches your
assets. And finally,
there's a dividend principle.
If you cannot find investments that make
your hurdle rate, find a way to get the
cash back to your stockholders.
Whether you do it in the form of dividends
or buybacks will depend on what kind
of stockholders you have and what they
prefer. So the first principles
of corporate finance are simple.
It is in the process of practicing them
that we make them much too complex and we
end up making mistakes. So when in doubt,
go back to these first principles.
It's amazing how often they can give you
the right answer to even the most
complicated questions you face in running
a business. Thank you very much for
listening for these 36 sessions.
I've enjoyed this journey,
and I hope that you've learned something
along the way as well.
♪ [music] ♪